i just i'm just i'm just up against that
resistance of the way i feel and i keep
making the excuse that it's because i'm
a girl and i think there's differences
between them
so
something that i never used an excuse
for in the past is being a girl but now
i'm like it's because i'm a girl
it's it's really clear that women are
just little men i mean they're identical
i mean that assumption has been in
medicine until about oh 15 20 years ago
we started looking at differences even
in fasting studies
and
i do know we've had 70 000 people go
through my fasting challenge which is a
free thing you don't even have to buy
the book but it's fastthisway.com
which is by the way the name of my
fasting book and i've had women from
22 all the way up to 82
say the same thing oh my god i just went
24 hours without eating
and i didn't notice it didn't bother me
i thought i couldn't do it so where you
are danica is totally normal you and i
were both told
if you don't eat five or six times a day
your body will go into starvation mode
and then you'll get fat right you heard
this before i bought that
totally and when i was at that 300 pound
level i was terrified in fact that's why
i had a shaman drop me off in a cave for
four days and i write about that in the
book
because
i knew that i would be hangry and
hypogly [ __ ] and i would yell at
people i cared about and i was afraid of
being alone and i knew i would eat if i
was lonely and i went through
all of these things going all right i'm
gonna have to be like 10 miles away from
any other human to do it that was how
big my fear was and i did fast for four
days
but you don't have to fast for four days
you as a woman there are new studies
that look at women and men
12-hour fasts three times a week create
metabolic benefits like do that
you can do that because you sleep for
like eight hours i try okay
so if you have an eight-hour
sleep that means stop eating after
dinner
okay have dinner at six four hours
before bedtime sleep sleep eight hours
right congratulations you're an
intermittent faster
and then you wake up you go you know
what i'm just gonna wait a little while
before i eat right what's that what's
that gonna be uh and that could be
suddenly it's a 14 hour fast but that's
all we're talking about because sleep
time counts as fasting time yeah and so
a lot of women are saying well i should
do an 18-hour fast every day right it
doesn't work and there's a chapter in
fastest way specific to the research on
women and what you'll find is
that if you look at the amount of stress
your body's under from all sources that
determines the length of your fast so if
you wake up and you're thinking god i
slept so well everything is perfect you
know i i'm just feeling really good and
i haven't lifted heavy i don't have some
high stress
race or event or something
i'm probably going to fast for longer
today because
fasting is a form of exercise or stress
for your body but if instead you say i
slept like garbage last night you know
maybe you had a hot flushes
or you know come
i mean i'm not that old yet no but
people listening are yeah you're right
you're 100 right
and that's a stressor and that's a
stressor
and you're super chill it's actually
really interesting
but
you
you go into all these things where okay
you people have fights they have a cold
right you something's not right well
okay how much is on that side of the
scale
and
if you're saying well okay today i was
already kind of wrecked i think i'll go
fast for
24 hours and i'll lift heavy at the gym
and i'll get on an airplane and fly
somewhere
it's too much and so
women and men both
are capable of fasting and women will
hit the stress wall of fasting before
men do on average
and i love getting to talk with someone
who totally gets all the driving
analogies so the old expression of
hitting the wall we know where that
comes from right well
when you learn how to manage your
biology and how to fast
without being hungry
what it does is it moves the wall very
far away so i have more resilience and
power and energy than i ever did before
that gives you time to build up speed
so you still can hit the wall and i i
teach for women that the fasting wall
when you over fast is about four to six
weeks and what happened is the first
week oh my god i did it and then next
week
every day correct is this every day
every day it could be even five six days
a week but you keep making longer and
pretty soon you're going to say i'm only
doing dinner and then with dinner oh
that's too much i'll just fast every
weekend and eventually you get to this
point where you know it worked but now
you're not feeling as good since it used
to work you're to do it even more it's
called the fasting trap and it works
with a vegan diet it works with the keto
diet it works with anything that works
at the right amount you go past the
goldilocks zone sure first sign bad
sleep so the way you would know that
your fasting wasn't working is you wake
up in the morning you feel like you're
hungover but you didn't drink anything
the night before and the second sign is
monthly irregularity in your cycle
right that's weird it's normally
predictable and now it's not
well okay maybe you should actually eat
a little bit more or more often and the
third thing if you keep pushing yourself
and by the way people who might i don't
know drive race cars or be professional
athletes or be hardcore entrepreneurs
like the type a people we are the ones
who are gonna push harder right and then
you say oh my hair is getting thin and
it's funny so that's the four to six
week i'm fasting too much thing for
women
but then for men
it's kind of similar but it takes less
usually six to eight weeks
and for men it's
sleep quality goes away and then i'm
waking up without a kickstand that's
weird and then the third thing is
my hair is thinning as well
and so what we're doing here is we're
saying don't over train and as you know
if you exercise three hours a day every
day you start to not feel good well it's
the same with fasting so that's the big
thing for women is it's okay
to not fast the same way every day and
shorter fast
when you're already
having other stressors and longer fast
when you're not commenting
yeah
and you know more than most people about
the feeling of fear like you're in a car
it's going really fast okay and there's
a party that says i'm going to die and
then there's a party who says i know i
can put the brakes on half a second
later or whatever it is you do i mean
i've been on a track but not like you so
you know there's that that edge you play
with oh yeah it's the name of the game
right well we all have that edge around
food
right and so oh my god i'm gonna die and
it actually it takes me 90 days to
starve to death but you sure feel like
you're gonna die and you have more time
before you put the brakes on then then
you feel like you do and then you allow
your body and your reflexes
to tell you what to do right you get
this way with fasting but only after you
drop the fear and that's the whole
reason i wrote a book on fasting was was
that it's a psychological thing about oh
my god i'm gonna die i didn't have tacos
at noon you're not going to die but man
you feel like you're going to die and
this was what you had to overcome those
four days in the cave right or when were
you in a cave were you in the wilderness
what were you taking anything was it
water was this a ayahuasca journey for
four days what was it i was literally by
myself in a cave with a sleeping bag a
fire a knife and a big big bottle of
water
i mean this is i resonated so much when
i heard that i i don't remember when i
heard that it was a while ago and i was
like that's how i feel like i might die
people know i'm a little food obsessed
at least i don't like throwing food away
i always have food on me i always have a
snack with me like it's always got to be
around because at that sort of i'd say
six hour mark during the day i'm like i
i might not even feel
hungry actually my mood shifts before i
feel hungry why is that
well you're getting hangry and what's
going on there is your body runs only on
glucose
and it's not metabolically flexible
and when you eat protein it can convert
to sugar in the body
and so
your body when you go for longer periods
of time without food or if you decide to
go on a keto diet for brief periods keto
is not good for men or women if you just
do it forever a lot of people keep
trying to do that that's bad
but you don't have to go keto you can
just do the intermittent fasting thing
and your ketones will rise and what
happens is the body goes you know what i
guess i should be pretty good at burning
fat and pretty good at burning sugar and
when the body burns fat your brains your
neurons are so happy because fat has
more calories than sugar so when you
burn that the neurons like yeah we
wanted more power we have more power and
more focus
so you get that like i can't imagine
doing a mental high performance thing
without having some ketones present and
i i say that because i know how i feel
but i also know because i run a
neuroscience lab to teach people's
brains to become high performance it's
called 40 years of zen and people come
and spend five days with stuff glued to
their head and if i don't give them mct
oil which helps to make ketones that
feed those neurons they can't do the
high performance meditation learning
stuff that they're capable of
and so you're sitting there going okay i
want to be fast
then you want to teach your metabolism
you should be able to burn fat and you
should be able to kick over and burn
sugar as well and people only go keto
they can't burn sugar anymore and they
get insulin resistant so in your case
your body says
emergency could you eat because it's
learned to always expect sugar and when
you teach the body not you consciously
but the body to just be calm and go oh
there's no sugar here i'm not going to
die what i'm going to do is i'm going to
kick over my fat burning enzymes and i'm
going to start metabolizing fat and then
the calmness and the energy kicks on